so one of the most popular questions and
video requests that I've received since
koala 4 has been released is to cover
the giant bird that create a Senate race
encounter while in Helheim the bird
itself doesn't really seem to do
anything other than sit on its perch and
fly run in the background so initially I
thought this bird could have been the
wise eagle that sits atop the Yggdrasil
perhaps the biggest hint were given as
to who this bird actually is is when the
bird begins to fly you can visually see
the levels of wind change and there is a
bird in Norse mythology who was thought
to be responsible for control in the
wind
that bird was referred to as race vulgar
and at times it was thought to be almost
identical to the wise eagle house Felger
was initially one of the owner so a
giant as they would be referred to in
the game who chose to take the form of
an eagle the name itself is thought of
derive from the Old Norse meaning one
who swallows corpses so maybe we can
assume along with nidhogg oh they were
responsible for devouring those who may
have committed an unspeakable crime it's
believed that the bird would reside on
the northern edge of the heavens at the
end of the world overlooking Helheim and
because of its sheer size whenever it
flapped its wings and took flight it
would cause the winds to blow now I
noticed video is a lot shorter than
normal but sadly there just isn't too
many mentions of face value in Norse
mythology itself we are about halfway
through our series exploring the
mythology behind God of War so if you
have any suggestions or thoughts then
please let me know in the comments below
and as always I've been your host
mythology and fiction explained